[Musique]
madame monsieur bonsoir le pilote
brésilien ayrton senna est mort cet
après midi à l'hôpital de bologne en
italie après un terrible accident au
cours du grand prix de saint marin
nous allons bien évidemment concentre
consacré l'essentiel de cette édition à
cette information nous retracerons la
carrière de senna avec nos invités
jacques laffite qui est en direct de
nevers et aux côtés de notre envoyé
spécial à imola lionel chamoulaud jean
todt le patron de l'écurie ferrari
ayrton senna rouler à plus de 300
kilomètres à l'heure quand sa voiture
est sortie de la piste au même endroit
que l'autrichien ratzenberger qui s'est
tué hier yann lavoix 14h16 la caméra
embarqué dans la voiture de schumacher
est braquée sur la williams renault des
retombées naît lorsque celle ci pour des
raisons encore inconnues quitte la piste
à près de 260 km/heure
entre l'instant où senna perd le
contrôle de sa voiture et l'instant où
il heurte le mur une seconde à peine
s'est écoulé
l'impact contre le mur est significatif
le choc a été terrible
rapidement le brésilien est secouru mais
il va rester de longues minutes inanimée
dans sa voiture toutes ces images sont
retransmises en direct dans le stand
williams renault
c'est la consternation lorsque les
docteurs extrait sénat de sa voiture on
constate alors que les membres
inférieurs du pilote ne sont pas
touchées mais qu'en revanche l'équipe
médicale s'emploie à le ranimer
en fait immédiatement les docteurs
pratique une intubation avec ventilation
et une mini trachéotomie interventions
opérées à même la piste pendant plus
d'un quart d'heure lorsqu'il est jugée
transportable il est amené jusqu'à
l'hélicoptère
le pilote est alors dans un coma graves
lorsqu'ils arrivent à l'hôpital de
bologne les médecins constatent des
fractures multiples à la base du crâne
et des problèmes neuro chirurgie qu à
17h39 son état jugé dramatique
peu après 18 heures son décès est
annoncée officiellement à 34 ans à
ayrton senna a été considéré par les
professionnels et par les amateurs de
formule 1 comme le plus grand on
l'appeler l'artiste en l'appeler magic
senna
laurent frédéric bollée 13h52 cet
après-midi ayrton senna enfile sa
cagoule
le dernier geste avant le drame 1984
sous la pluie à monaco ayrton da silva
dit ayrton senna est un inconnu mais se
révèle en terminant deuxième un
phénomène est née une légende aussi
celle d'un pilote littéralement génial
celle d'un homme froid au coeur chaud
amoureux fou de la vitesse et de ses
vertiges sénat surnommé aussitôt magic
ou iti qui empoche son premier grand
prix à 25 ans sous la pluie encore sénat
à cette époque jeunes loups qui se
régalent et conditions de course extrême
c'est la jeunesse d'un pilote derrière
lequel perce un destin mondial mais
également une propension à tutoyer le
danger 1989 japon accrochage avec alain
prost
1990 japon encore nouvel accrochage
délibéré cette fois avec prost
la rivalité entre les deux champions
atteint un seuil critique senna avoue sa
culpabilité et prouve une détermination
qui flirte souvent avec du mysticisme
d'autres accrochages et accidents
jalonnent sa carrière sénat aime répéter
qu'il aime frôlé ses limites et celles
de sa machine
certains le considèrent dangereux il est
même condamné une fois par la fédération
mais il est aussi triple champion du
monde et son aura ressemble à celle de
jim clark sénat qu'il y a deux jours en
arrivant imola avoué en tout cas son
inquiétude
peut-être une prémonition j'avais de
mauvaises sensations pour conduire la
voiture et l'a poussée vers ses limites
je n'ai pas eu tour sur lequel je me
suis senti vraiment encore facilement à
l'aise puis avec tous ces accidents
je n'étais pas vraiment confiant sénat
avait signé cette année pour l'écurie
williams-renault sans doute la meilleure
on lui promettait un quatrième titre de
champion du monde mais un début de
saison catastrophique le reléguer au
second plan derrière schumacher senna en
difficulté cette année
mais senna qui a écrit quelques unes
parmi des plus belles pages du sport
automobile
il est mort à la passion d'un grand
artiste en pleine représentation en
plein grand prix en pleine gloire
à 34 ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes en direct avec jacques
laffite qui se trouve à nevers jacques
laffite bonsoir vous étiez à magny cours
toute la journée
vous avez couru je crois deux saisons
aux côtés de d'ayrton senna sur les
mêmes circuits
qu'est-ce qui le caractérisait le mieux
caractériser de ayrton senna c'est
d'abord qu'il était trois fois champion
du monde que c'était un très grand
champion qui a fait sa carrière au début
un peu avec moi et qui a très vite
monter les échelons du fait de sa note
de sa compétence et de son talent et
qu'il était un garçon très courageux on
le disait fougue parfois oui il était
comme doivent dois tu dois être un
pilote de formule un fougueux attaquant
un peu et raisonnée un peu fou mais s'il
croit que ce sont les seules qualités
qu'on puisse avoir pour réussir en
formule 1 jamais le monde de la formule
1 n'avait connu un pareil week-end de
l'autrichien ratzenberger hier le
brésilien sénat aujourd'hui mais aussi
une série d'incidents pendant la course
qui ont fait au total douze blessés dans
les stands et dans les tribunes pascal
c'est bon
cette roue vient de blessés trois
mécaniciens des écuries ferrari et lotus
elle va poursuivre sa course sur la
piste juste avant le passage d'une
mclaren
une seconde plus tôt elle s'est arraché
de la voiture d'albert eto'o qui sortait
d'un de ces ravitaillements si critiqués
pour leur danger l'un des mécaniciens et
ce soir dans un état critique
il est alors 16 heures et c'en est trop
trop de drames trop de peur gerard berg
air demande l'arrêt de la course
en vain il faut dire que depuis
l'accident de senna une heure et demi
plus tôt une certaine panique règne à
imola
regardez cette scène se déroule dix
minutes après la neutralisation de la
course
on est en train de soigner le brésilien
et la voiture d'erik comas ce est encore
en piste problème de signalisation sans
doute
revenons maintenant avant le drame
premier départ carambolage entre pedro
lamy et djidji les taux est déjà une
affaire de roues qui s'envole dans la
tribune celle ci elle fera quatre
blessés parmi les spectateurs course
maudite et week end maudit
samedi c'était l'autrichien radson berg
et un bleu de la f1 qui quittaient la
route dans le dire à gilles villeneuve à
près de 300 km heure il mourra quelques
minutes plus tard et vendredi la jordan
de barrichello s'envolait dans ce qui
apparaît aujourd'hui comme un triste
présage mail ou au moins s'en est sorti
vivant
lionel chamoulaud est avec nous en
direct du circuit d'imola bonsoir lionel
vous avez suivi ce grand prix de saint
marin pendant tout le week-end
vous m'entendez petite difficulté de
liaison vous m'entendez lionel etienne
reçoit etienne vous étiez donc je disais
sur sur ce circuit pendant le grand prix
de saint-marin tout le week end
est ce que c'est un circuit on a
vraiment l'impression que c'est un
circuit extrêmement dangereux avec cette
accumulation d'accident peut savoir
etienne que effectivement ce circuit
d'imola fait partie des circuits les
plus rapides de la saison
pour vous donner une idée ici pour faire
la pole position il faut tourner au
dessus de 220 km heure de moyenne
lorsqu on peut noter également c'est que
d'essayer de très très grande ligne
droite il ya des courbes qui se prennent
aussi très rapidement notamment la
colombe est sorti et ayrton senna est le
problème c'est que tout le long de ce
circuit
eh bien il ya assez peu d'échappatoires
et il y a des murs et lorsque vous
sortez à 300 320 kilomètres heure comme
ça a été le cas hier pour atteindre girl
aujourd'hui pour ayrton senna est bien
le choc est frontal parce que le pilote
n'a pas tort de positionner la voiture
pour que les roues touchent en premier
ou l'arrière de la voiture
le choc est frontal ce qui veut dire que
l'impact est terrible car l'habitacle
des formule 1 ne se déforme plus car
avec les matériaux composites bâton on
arrive à faire un cockpit très très
solide mais c'est le corps qui prend
tout léger et le problème c'est qu'au
moment du choc fait état aujourd'hui
pour leurs tonnes c'est l'un est bien
notamment la tête à taper tellement
forte sur la rigidité de la coque et
bien que malheureusement le brésilien
n'a pas pu résister on pourrait peut
être qu'ils vont préparer deux de ses
problèmes de sécurité car
dans quinze jours par exemple bien
mousson à monaco là c'est un autre style
de problème les rails sont très très peu
il n'y a pas non plus d'échappatoire
alors évidemment ça des tellement
longtemps qu'il n'avait pas eu
d'accident formule 1 que on pensait que
tout avait été résolu mais maintenant le
greg le mans un petit peu changé les
voitures sont moins assiste
électroniquement on revient à des choses
plus simples des choses qui sont parfois
très simple et qui casse aussi très
simplement ce qui est en train de se
genre de problème lionel on avait
l'impression en regardant les images
qu'il n'y avait pas de protection sur
sur ses murs qui sont dans les cours des
circuits est ce qu'il ya une raison à
cela
mais à écouter tout simplement parce que
il y à environ un mètre cinquante à deux
mètres d'échappatoire une fois que les
voitures sortent et bien il n'y a pas de
place pour mettre des pneus car parfois
vous savez que au sortir d'une courbe
une voiture peut monter un petit peu sur
un vibreur sur l'herbe
mais il faut laisser un petit peu de
place derrière et là il n'y a pas
suffisamment de place pour mettre par
exemple un bac à sable ou pour m ou pour
mettre des pneus alors c'est la
conception même du du circuit qui pose
aujourd'hui un problème car maintenant
lorsqu'on construit un circuit nouveaux
circuits 9 est bien dans le tracé dans
le dessin ce circuit à chaque endroit
dangereux c'est à dire là où les pilotes
arrivent à très grande vitesse
et bien il y a des échappatoires il y a
des pneus il ya des bacs à sable il y à
des rails qui arrive sous l'effet de
l'impact parfois à se plier pour amortir
un petit peu le choc
malheureusement sur ce circuit d'imola
qui est un circuit traditionnel un vieux
circuit de la formule 1 il n'y a pas ce
genre d'aménagement et c'est sans doute
les questions que vont se poser
maintenant est bien et les pilotes les
organisateurs et puis aussi ceux qui ont
en charge de s'occuper de la sécurité
c'est à dire la fédération
internationale du sport automobile
jacques laffite est ce que vous vous
pensez vous aussi que l'on privilégie
désormais le spectacle à la à la
véritable sécurité des pilotes et des
spectateurs
on a on a décidé de différencier les
voitures par rapport à une certaine
année les voitures maintenant que
l'individu chamoulaud sont très très sûr
en conception et malheureusement le
corps humain ne peut plus subir léger
que qu'imposer par la vitesse en formule
1 alors aujourd'hui soit pour faire des
circuits soit je crois le plus simple
c'est demande à la fédération
constructeur de de faire des voitures
beaucoup moins rapide angers c'est à
dire diminuées l'aérodynamique des
voitures alors c'est pas facile à faire
ça se fera pas en 10 jours mais je crois
qu'il est temps aujourd'hui pour la
fédération et les pilotes de se pencher
sur problème parce que l'avertissement
est très sévère et
il ya deux pilotes sont morts
aujourd'hui alain prost et disait que le
dialogue était complètement coupée avec
les autorités de l'automobile au niveau
international bien sûr les comme
d'habitude les pilotes n'ont pas trop de
roche habite mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui après ce qu'il vient de
se passer
ayrton senna l'autrichien je pense que
les pilotes vont avoir un mot à dire et
je crois même les constructeurs parce
qu'on ne peut pas c'est un sport c'est
aussi un spectacle mais on ne doit pas
mourir pour ce spectacle là et surtout
pour ce sport je propose d'écouter
maintenant la réaction de jean todt qui
est actuellement le patron de l'écurie
ferrari jean todt qui répondait à un
lionel chamoulaud il ya quelques minutes
et qui parle lui de fatalité non je
prend effectivement qu'on peut parler de
fatalité ce soir ça fait très longtemps
qu'il n'y avait pas eu
d'accidents de cette violence avec de
telles conséquences en formule 1
en fait on avait perdu l'habitude
d'accidents mortels est effectivement un
certain nombre d'années que on a fait
d'énormes progrès avec les voitures
aussi bien
dans la tenue des monocoques c'est à
dire là ce qu'on appelle aussi
l'habitacle de survie du pilote
et puis également avec la sécurité sur
les circuits
et puis là il se trouve que entre
vendredi samedi dimanche et où trois
accidents très graves qui s'est bien
terminée pour barrichello et puis 2 qui
se terminent les manière catastrophique
pour bryan berg est arrêtée là bravo
paul la sécurité lui voit l'alluré
chamoulaud vous êtes toujours en direct
avec nous dit mot là oui je vais vous
demander tout à l'heure mais la liaison
était mauvaise quelle a été la réaction
des pilotes dans les stands et les
mécaniciens dans les stands quand ils
ont appris la mort d'ayrton senna
vous imaginez bien que tout le monde
était complètement atterrée personne ne
croyait vraiment à cette nouvelle j'ai
croisé beaucoup de pilotes qui étaient
complètement hagard et les yeux embués
jean alesi notamment me dit écoute je ne
sais pas quoi dire je n'y crois pas je
préfère ne pas en parler ne pas y penser
c'est tellement c'est tellement terrible
vous imaginez bien que c'est vrai que
hier à zone burger s'est tuée est un
pilote comme connaissait pas et c'était
une toute nouvelle curiosité me tiens il
me fait un petit problème de sécurité
dans cette nouvelle écurie mais on s'est
rendu compte aux rues que ça pouvait
arriver à l'écurie championne du monde
au pilote le plus prestigieux encore en
exercice et tout le monde était
complètement atterrée vous savez
comportent souvent de fatalité on dit
c'est peut-être la loi des séries et
très souvent les sportifs essaie
d'évacuer le mauvais sort en y pensant
pas trop mais je pense que ce soir eh
bien tout le monde pensera très très
fort à ayrton senna et tout le monde se
dira peut-être qu'il faut de toute façon
continuer continuer à courir continue
pour pour la passion automobile met pas
dans n'importe quelle condition et il
faudra bien arriver à trouver des
solutions pour que ce spectacle ne sont
pas un spectacle qui amène jusqu'à la
mort des pilotes en direct jacques
laffite vous avez vous même je crois a
été victime d'un accident extrêmement
grave moment auquel vous avez décidé
d'arrêter la compétition qu'est ce que
l'on ressent dans ces cas là quand on a
un accident ou même quand un pilote
d'essai dès qu'on est dans la même
course que lui en général quand j'étais
pilote et qu'il y avait un accident très
grave y en a eu beaucoup malheureusement
on se sent toujours beaucoup plus fort
que le voisin et on pense que ça ne peut
arriver qu aux autres et qu'on est plus
balèze que l'autre mais on s'est aperçu
avec ratzenberger et senna que ça peut
aussi arriver aux meilleurs et c'est
bien là le problème je dire qu'il faut
se poser aujourd'hui comment on va faire
pour rétablir un semblant de sécurité en
formule 1 parce que ça peut arriver
demain matin après demain il ya eu trop
bu trop eu de pépins depuis cinq six
mois donc on est arrivé à un point de
non-retour ya une échéance et il faut
absolument tous les pilotes et la
fédération s'en occupe ayrton senna est
le 23e pilotes à se tuer sur un circuit
automobile depuis la création des
épreuves de formule 1 tiret kurt et
comme senna il était le chouchou du
public comme senna il est mort en pleine
gloire
gilles villeneuve se tue lors des essais
en belgique sa ferrari vient de heurter
la renault sa voiture se désintègre
gilles villeneuve est éjecté de
l'habitacle départ du grand prix
d'italie en 78 au milieu du peloton
plusieurs voitures s'accrochent les
réservoirs gr b d'essence éclate et
lincendie ronnie peterson périr à brûler
le fut encore au grand prix de monaco
l'italien lorenzo bandini percute le
rail lui aussi pereira brûler le feu
toujours mais pour un miraculé
niki lauda perd le contrôle de sa
ferrari il recevra l'extrême onction
mais il s'en sortira lui jacques laffite
qu'est-ce qui peut décider un pilote en
voyant des images aussi terrible que
celle que l'on a vue aujourd'hui à
remonter dans sa voiture dans les jours
qui suivent une passion simplement je
crois que c'est la passion de tous les
sportifs et que vous savez aussi bien
c'est d'un coeur à sa mère est que les
autres ont choisi de faire un métier
tout le monde sait que notre métier est
un métier très dangereux on l'acceptent
mais il est vrai que par moments cas
c'est une pièce mécanique et sortir de
la route c'est une acceptation qui est
pas toujours facile à avaler parce que
se planter se tuer de sa faute mais là
franchement tous les accidents nous
avons vu pendant ce week-end n'ont rien
à voir avec la la qualité du pilote
c'est simplement une heure un problème
mécanique l'unss et son aileron sénat
doit être une crevaison lente ou alors
un bris mécanique que d'une suspension
le pauvre barrichello qui s'en est bien
sorti c'était une crevaison je crois
donc vous voyez bien que c'est pas
l'erreur du pilote les pilotes on n'est
pas des fous comme on dit on sait
exactement où l'on en est ce que l'on
fait mais on accepte cet incident
mécanique mais il y en a trop que je
veux dire image dérisoire et ce sera la
dernière ce grand prix de saint-marin a
été remportée par l'allemand michael
schumacher
les pilotes ont décidé de se réunir
vendredi à monaco pour faire des
propositions à la fédération
internationale automobile propositions
en matière de sécurité voilà vous voyez
ici l'image de l'allemand michael
schumacher
jacques laffite un dernier mot alain
prost disait lui aussi il a été souvent
le concurrent de bertone sénat dans
beaucoup de compétitions disait aussi
que qu'ayrton senna était véritablement
un très très grand champion
c'était certainement un des plus grands
champions de la décennie ils proches et
clark lauda prost est maintenant sénat
c'est un grand champion qui vient de
disparaître
et on doit se poser la question je me
répète qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour
éviter ce genre de drame
vous pensez qu'il aurait fallu arrêter
cette course quand il ya eu cet accident
hier et puis maintenant aujourd'hui
l'accident d'ayrton senna
non parce qu'il faut pas bon c'est vrai
qu'à la fatalité il ya la loi des séries
mais on peut pas arrêter un spectacle
parce qu'un des problèmes mécaniques sur
une voiture il faut il faut savoir que
ce métier dangereux que la course est un
métier très dangereux on en accepte les
risques les constructeurs les pilotes
les sponsors tout le monde mais c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui il faut quand même
se poser la question est ce que le jeu
en vaut la chandelle voilà moi je pose
cette question personne sénat disait
hier où il ya 48 heures je crois qu'il
avait eu un espèce de de pressentiment
est ce que vous vous ressentez parfois
un danger avant avant une course d'un
danger particulier vous savez j'ai vu
l'accident de barrichello vendredi en
regardant les essais j'ai vu l'accident
d'hier de ratzenberger et je me suis dit
j'étais avec des copains on a dit et un
regarde c'est la série moi je me
souviens qu'à l'époque ça s'est toujours
passé comme ça et que je dis il faut que
tu fasses gafla ce week-end parce qu'il
ya là trop quoi je dirais même si la
course est invraisemblable il se passe
rien pendant dix ans et d'un seul coup
tout au long mais c'était un rappel
nécessaire pour faire comprendre aux
gens qu'il faut changer quelque chose
lionel chamoulaud et ayrton senna avait
avait parlé il ya 48 heures
effectivement de ceux de ce mauvais
pressentiment de ce mauvais feeling
comme dit les comme disent les
spécialistes qu'il avait ressenti après
l'accident de de son compatriote
barrichello oui ça l'avait
particulièrement touchés parce que
barrichello est un jeune pilote
brésilien qui est née à sao paulo donc
ayrton senna était aussi de sao paulo et
il croyait beaucoup au talent de ce
jeune pilote ayrton senna justement
vendredi il avait rencontré juste après
la séance de thil avait réussi le
meilleur temps et justement il disait
qu'il y avait quelque chose qui ne lui
convenait pas et trouver que la piste
était changeante qu'il y avait de la
poussière à cause du vent qui a mené le
sable sur cette piste qu'il y avait à
son goût beaucoup trop d'accidents il ya
eu celui de de barrichello le plus
spectaculaire vient au moins cinq ou six
voitures qui sont parti en tête à queue
qui sont allés dans les bacs à sable qui
ont tapé un petit peu le mur on n'a pas
parlé parce que ce n'était pas de très
grave accident mais c'était quand même
étonnant de voir à quel point on aime
lui d'ailleurs avait été surprise au
freinage de tout ça était parti en tête
à queue
ainsi que michael schumacher des pilotes
et les plus en vue avait eu des
problèmes et au moment de cette
interview après les essais il semblait
un petit peu marre qu elle était pâle il
était blanc et on avait commencé les
interviews et il n'arrivait pas à parler
de barrichello il avait préféré se
relaxer un petit peu se changer avant
d'accepter l'interview et puis hier
c'est lui qui est allé lorsque résonnent
burger a été victime de cet accident
mortel s'est lui au nom de pilote qui
est allé sur place se rendre compte de
ce qui s'était passé lorsqu'il a appris
que le pilote autrichien était mort eh
bien il a décidé de ne pas prendre part
aux essais penser plus du tout à la pole
position il a quitté le circuit juste
après l annonce de cette nouvelle et
donc c'est vrai que ce pressentiment si
ce mauvais sentiment en tout cas et bien
habiter à ayrton senna lui qui croyait
beaucoup au ciel qu'il s'en remettait
souvent à dieu lorsqu'il parlait de sa
carrière de sa façon de conduire et bien
sans doute qu'il avait peut-être quelque
chose au fond de lui qui lui faisait un
signe un petit signe du destin
malheureusement daniel vous qui était à
imola donc tout le week-end vous avez
l'impression qu'avec la mort de cette
star tellement immense dans le milieu de
la formule 1 il ya une fracture qui
vient de s'opérer ou que les choses vont
finalement redémarrer dans quelques
jours dans quelques semaines un petit
peu comme avant je dirais lorsque l'on
parle comme cela à chaud vraiment on est
tellement marquée qu on peut se dire
qu'il ya toute une génération qui est
parti car nelson piquet arrêté conduire
en formule 1 nigel mansell a choisi
d'aller couvrir aux états unis alain
prost a pris sa retraite
ayrton senna le dernier des quatre
grands des années 80 90 et bien n'est
plus là on a l'impression effectivement
que d'un seul coup la formule 1 a perdu
toutes ses toutes ces têtes tous et
toutes ses stars mais je pense que il va
falloir continuer car il ya de jeunes
talents qui arrivent et qui je pense
seront s'inspirer de ce qui est arrivé à
leurs aînés car même si pendant une
douzaine d'années il n'y a pas eu
d'accidents mortels en course eh bien on
se souvient bien sûr on en parlait tout
à l'heure
avec tous ces accidents se souvient que
ce sport a toujours été très très
dangereux je pense que bernie
ecclecstone le président de la focale
président la foca qui gère l'image de la
formule 1 ainsi que les intérêts de la
formule 1 est bien sûr à réagir avec max
mosley le président la fédération
internationale pour que justement en
mondiovision n'assiste plus à des drames
tels que ce qu'on a vécu ce week-end ici
à imola merci beaucoup de lionel peut
être une dernière intervention de
jacques laffite jacques laffite on avait
véritablement l'impression quand l'on
voit ces images que la mort et de ses
pilotes et le spectacle que procure la
formule 1 ne sont pas véritablement
compatible c'est pas compatible
malheureusement c'est c'est la loi un
pilote prend des risques un pilote ce
tube et vous savez très bien comme moi
ont eu les cheveux les étals heures le
spectacle va continuer le sport
automobile continuera avec ou sans senna
mais c'est une grande tristesse pour
nous ce soir parce qu'on vient de perdre
deux champions et c'est un lourd tribut
à la course aux huiles que le sport ils
viennent donner à l'avis de ses deux
garçons et moi je considère que
évidemment la formule 1 continuera mais
sans engager de polémique il faut
maintenant que ecclestone et toute la
clique se mettre en rapport avec les
pilotes et la fédération pour trouver
une solution pour éviter ce genre de
drame mondovision comme le disait lionel
chamoulaud merci beaucoup
zagré site merci lionel d'avoir été en
direct depuis imola voilà donc ce que
nous pouvions dire ce soir sur la mort
d'ayrton senna je vous rappelle qu'il
avait 34 ans qu'il avait été trois fois
champion du monde de formule 1 que
c'était une immense star l'actualité à
l'étranger maintenant avec l'afrique du
sud dans un instant nous serons en
direct avec l'un des hommes qui
symbolise sans doute le mieux les
efforts menés depuis des dizaines
d'années pour construire la démocratie
dans le pays
monseigneur desmond tutu prix nobel de
la paix en 1984 est avec nous ce soir en
direct du cap
le dépouillement se poursuit le parti de
nelson mandela obtiendrait 54% des voix
d'après les premières estimations
bernard lebrun et alain st sont en
afrique du sud le poids de la démocratie
blanc et noir transportant les urnes
sous la hotte vigiles
de l'armée qui garantit la protection
des suffrages populaires l'image
ordinaire de la journée en afrique du
sud
une image impensable il ya encore quatre
ans l'histoire en marche durant la
campagne
nelson mandela avait promis du travail à
son peuple il en a dès aujourd'hui un
travail énorme dont jaillira sa liberté
dépouillé 1 1 23 million 700 mille
bulletins en plus des scrutateurs chaque
parti politique à sur place son
représentant sa mission vérifier de visu
le résultat annoncé en retrait les
observateurs internationaux
j'ai le sentiment que c'est très content
l'été mais c'est parce que c'est ça doit
être comme ça parce que nous savons que
c'est la première élection c'est très
très compliqué ça va pas à terminer ce
soit parce que là les procédures là
chaque parti contrôle le même les petits
détails là donc je pense aussi qu'il
n'ya pas il n'y a pas de confiance entre
les parties quand il
et ils contrôlent les détails retenue
derrière les vitres les médias comme le
public n'ont pas accès à la salle
mais pas besoin de son on lit le nom du
gagnant sur les lèvres à insee heinz et
l'african national congress de nelson
mandela vols vers la victoire
54% des 3 millions de bulletins
dépouillés 33% pour le président de
clerck
ce ne sont que des tendances et les
scrutateurs sont déjà fatigués en milieu
d'après midi la commission électorale a
fait appel à de nouveaux bénévoles pour
accélérer les opérations
l'objectif est simple achevé le
dépouillement ce soir à minuit
l'afrique du sud est impatiente de
connaître le résultat de ces élections
il en va de son avenir et de sa sécurité
monseigneur desmond tutu bonsoir vous
m'entendez bien connu une ligne s fruits
tout à fait bonsoir je voudrais avoir
votre votre première impression sur ces
premiers résultats qui nous parviennent
d'afrique du sud manche pipeau ces
résultats
indique que ce que beaucoup attendaient
à savoir une victoire tout à fait nette
en faveur de la haine c'est dans
certaines régions du pays
les semble que le parti nationaliste
notamment dans la province du cap va
remporter les élections monsieur une
aberration est ce que vous considérez
monseigneur que votre travail désormais
votre combat pour la paix est terminée
écoutez c'est une étape fondamentale
c'est une victoire incroyable
extraordinaire de notre peuple tout
entier
c'est une victoire de la démocratie
c'est une victoire pour l'afrique du sud
et merci grand merci à tous nos amis qui
vivent en france qui nous ont appuyés
dans nos luttes
est ce que vous allez vous vous engager
politiquement ou est-ce que vous
souhaitez rester en quelque sorte une
forme de deux médiateurs dans ce dans
cette nouvelle afrique du sud
non nous sommes toujours engagés
politiquement
mais nous ne sommes pas aligné sur un
parti nous serons là pour faire en sorte
que le nouveau gouvernement se fasse
interprète des pauvres et des de ceux
qui sont sans abri mais si l'on vous
proposait par exemple un poste dans un
futur gouvernement est ce que vous
l'accepteriez nos cellules et n'a
certainement pas j'ai dit
précédemment que je n'avais pas
d'ambition politique
mais de toute façon je ne suis pas assez
intelligent pour être en politique
vous êtes extrêmement modeste
monseigneur on vous a vu l'autre jour au
moment du vote
sauté de joie en disant c'est formidable
c'est formidable est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire quels ont été les épreuves les
plus dures que vous avez vécu au cours
de ces 20 de ses 30 dernières années
dans dans ce combat pour la démocratie
et doit s'y disait bien l'épreuve un peu
pénible c'était la dénomination de ce
qu'ils étaient victimes de leurs
bourreaux tout ça dure et fort longtemps
et pendant très longtemps les ressources
de mon beau pays de ce pays si riche ont
été gaspillés et ont été affectés
destination tout à fait un contre nature
crackdown et beaucoup de gens ont vu
leur niveau de vie baisser
maintenant nous voyons une libération
remarquable pour les noirs aussi bien
que pour les blancs nous sommes tous
maintenant fiers d'être des africains du
sud est la seule question qui se pose
est celle de savoir pourquoi avons-nous
attendu si longtemps
pourquoi avons nous perdu tant de
personnalités extraordinaires que dieu
nous a donné mais ces richesses
précisément dont vous parliez
monseigneur est-ce que vous pensez que
les blancs vont les partager facilement
avec les noirs écoutez foden sommes
parfaitement
il est infiniment préférable pour eux de
réduire un tout petit peu leur niveau de
vie de partager le reste s'il ne partage
pas leurs recherches ils risquent de
perdre tout ne voulons pas dépouiller
les blancs nous voulons simplement
définir la façon de partager les
richesses de notre pays de les partager
d'une façon plus équitable comment aider
les enfants noirs pour qu'ils puissent
améliorer dans le niveau d'éducation non
seulement pour eux mêmes mais pour le
pays également dont ils sont une
ressource comment améliorer la santé
publique
comment dispensé des soins à tous et
surtout aux plus pauvres
pas seulement pour et à cause des
pauvres mais pour le béa imaginer une
épidémie de choléra qui éclatent parmi
le noir est bien cette épidémie ne va
pas se limiter aux zones où habitent les
noirs elle va se propager ailleurs là où
habitent les blancs donc dans notre
intérêt bien compris il faudra
travailler pour le bien de tous merci
beaucoup monseigneur desmond tout
d'avoir été en direct avec nous depuis
le cap donc je vous rappelle que les
résultats officiels de ces premières
élections multiraciales en afrique du
sud devraient être connus demain soir ou
mardi matin
les rwandais ne vote pas il fuit leur
pays le plus vite possible pour échapper
à la guerre un exode de plusieurs
centaines de milliers de personnes dans
des conditions terribles gérard beaufils
hommes femmes enfants vieillards sont
sur les routes de l'exode avec seulement
pour bagage un maigre baluchon les
dizaines de milliers de rwandais tentent
de fuir actuellement leur pays ou
massacres et exactions se poursuivent
pour toutes ces victimes de la
purification ethnique et de la guerre
civile qui fait rage
le seul salut se trouve dans la fuite
vers les pays voisins
le zaïre le burundi et la tanzanie
il s'agit là peut-être du plus grand
déplacement de population de toute
l'histoire
hier cent mille personnes ont pu
franchir la frontière avec la tanzanie
après avoir abandonné les armes qu'il
transportait pour se défendre contre les
pillards qu'ils n'hésitent pas à jeter
femmes et enfants dans les marigots
après les avoir détroussé aujourd'hui
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
personnes sont bloquées par les rebelles
rwandais qui ont fermé la frontière avec
la tanzanie
en dépit des efforts de l'armée pour les
protéger ces réfugiés sont en danger de
mort
et de plus les organisations
humanitaires annonce que leurs stocks
d'eau et de nourriture seront épuisés
dans quatre à cinq jours au proche
orient le gouvernement israélien a
désigné son premier ministre itzhak
rabin pour signé mercredi au caire
l'accord d'autonomie avec les
palestiniens
et puis en bosnie les casques bleus ont
à nouveau été visés par des tirs
d'artillerie serbe près de gorazde par
ailleurs deux journalistes américains
ont été tués aujourd'hui ils ont sauté
sur une mine près de mostar l'amiral
lanxade le chef d'état major des armées
étaient aujourd'hui à sarai et il y a un
an pierre bérégovoy décidé de mettre fin
à ses jours dans l'hommage qui lui est
rendu aujourd'hui à nevers le président
de la république françois mitterrand a
eu cette phrase pierre bérégovoy manque
à la france à nevers guilaine chenu yves
bas avec quelques notes de musique la
ville de nevers a voulu se souvenir de
son ancien maire le stabat mater de
francis poulenc s'élève une musique
choisie parce que modern recueillies et
lumineuse
un an après la mort de pierre bérégovoy
reste ici le chagrin et parfois des
rancoeurs c'était quelqu'un en a perdu
gros il restera toujours gravé dans
notre coeur et notre vie aujourd'hui à
plus de doute pour savoir si c'était
injuste ou pas juste crois
qu'aujourd'hui les gens sont convaincus
que ceux qui ont pu en dire du mal se
sont trompés ce qu'on en dit du bien ou
raison dans la matinée au cimetière des
filets du souvenir avec ses amis
syndicalistes élus locaux de nevers et
de toute la lumière autour de la nuit
sera selon tehran venu saluer seule la
mémoire de son ancien premier ministre
il famille de gauche qui veut faire
taire les polémiques de ces derniers
jours ait montré son union mais la
réconciliation et plus afficher le
naturel
l'important c'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est finalement le
rassemblement
autour de pierre bérégovoy en présence
du chef de l'état et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui tout ça est d'oublier
et pour preuve une photo françois
mitterrand aux côtés de tous les
dirigeants du parti socialiste pour
mettre fin aux tensions entre l'élysée
le parti union que le président appelait
de ses voeux
cette fois devant un parterre d'amis
politiques nous sommes là réunis et nous
avons peut-être besoin de communiquer un
instant au delà du tout le reste qui ne
compte pas pour sentir notre unité
ce qui nous réunit ce qui fait de nous
tous aussi chez une famille élargie
une journée où les hommages se sont
succédé comme ici des fleurs et quelques
brins de muguet déposés au bord d'un
canal ou pierre bérégovoy s'est donné la
mort il ya un an
au centre de ce week-end de politique du
1er mai un grand thème l'emploi la
gauche y consacrer ces assises à rennes
hier et à port marly aujourd'hui
philippe séguin devant les responsables
du rpr a proposé un référendum sur
l'emploi véronique saint-olivier
frédéric de là il y a un an philippe
séguin jetait un pavé dans la mare en
dénonçant à propos du chômage à munich
social
aujourd'hui jacques chirac reprend
l'idée la lutte contre le chômage sera
bien au coeur du débat présidentiel
alors philippe séguin charge de nouveau
en éclaireur par opposition à edouard
balladur qui évoque les blocages de la
société il fixe de nouvelles
perspectives
oui ou non sommes-nous capables de
concevoir et de mettre en chantier une
société garantissant la pleine activité
dont l'exclusion 0 et devant des
militants tout à qui philippe séguin
propose alors aux présidentiables
jacques chirac d' associer tous les
français à cette bataille là alors je ne
vois qu'un moyen pour fonder les
réorientations à terme le référendum et
plus précisément un référendum sur
l'activité
l'esprit gaulliste souffler jacques
chirac pouvaient attiser la flamme
il met pas trop de dire que la france a
besoin d'un nouveau souffle et d'un
souffle qu'il soit gaulliste
c'était aussi le jour du muguet jacques
chirac a donc distribué les fleurs un
bouquet pour alain juppé un bouquet pour
philippe séguin il faut bien cela la
campagne présidentielle s'annonce rude
jean-marie le pen et ses troupes avaient
eux choisi pour la traditionnelle fête
de jeanne d'arc d'engager une nouvelle
fois la bataille contre l'europe de
maëstricht plusieurs milliers de
militants du front national se sont
rassemblés place du palais royal pour
écouter le discours de leur président
sur le thème contre l'europe de
maastricht tu allais la france
quant aux syndicats ils ont fêté leur
premier met ensemble en province mais en
ordre dispersé à paris où seule la cgt a
défilé
frédéric rota je viens tous les ans je
joue sur l'entrée le 1er mai comme comme
tout le monde c'est tout
l'union j'ai pas de ma faute on a du mal
à se souvenir de la dernière
manifestation unitaire mais qu'importe
la seule cgt fidèle à la tradition a
réuni entre quinze et vingt mille
personnes entre république et nation
il faut dire qu'une trentaine
d'organisations aux importantes
s'étaient jointes au défi les slogans
contre le chômage et l'exclusion
inquiétudes de la cgt quant à l'avenir
de la protection sociale
plusieurs projets sont aujourd'hui en
préparation par le gouvernement il
débouche et ils traduisent tous une même
volonté soumettre la protection sociale
à la loi de la rentabilité financière
la cgt annonce sur ce thème
l'organisation dès aujourd'hui d'un
vaste débat national par le biais d'une
pétition
l appareil réaffirmé son attachement à
la réduction du temps de travail sans
réduction de salaire pour gagner cette
bataille de l'emploi un peu partout à
travers la france des personnes au
chômage ont entamé une grande marche
vers paris où une manifestation
nationale aura lieu le 28 mai prochain
renaud fessaguet et christophe vignal
sont allés à lyon à la rencontre d'un
groupe de chômeurs partie il y a trois
semaines de toulon
en
nous ne voulons pas la charité vous
voulez des trois travailler moins pour
travailler tous tous ensemble marchant
jusqu'à paris cette nouvelle croisade
une croisade des temps de crise
depuis trois semaines une soixantaine de
chômeurs et de sdf toulonnais ont pris
la route à pied pour rejoindre paris le
28 mai prochain pour protester contre le
chômage et l'exclusion
j'en ai marre d'être oisives j'en ai
marre d'être en fin de droits j'ai
refusé le rmi depuis juillet l'année
dernière c'est une révolte individuelle
c'est ma dernière dignité par solidarité
parce que j'ai un fils qui est au
chômage
et puis finalement je prête aux assedic
et que je pense que il ya aussi protesté
contre le gâchis de des anciens dans les
boîtes qui sont qu'ils soient éliminés
parce que déjà retrouvé à 55 ans avant
d'arriver à lyon les marcheurs ont
progressé par petites étapes de 30
kilomètres par jour
le long de la nationale 7 partout
presque ils ont trouvé des mairies qui
ouvrent leurs portes et syndicats qui
nourrissait me dis halte au repas sous
les frondaisons
l'occasion de faire le point sur la
situation de chacun exemple didier
ancien maquettiste dans l'imprimerie
pendant la marche je m'arrête
je consacre une heure ou deux une
recherche d'emplois effectives mais pour
l'instant il n'y a eu aucune aucune
réponse
la marche c'est justement destinés à ce
que à travers les villes à travers la
france bon on dise à tout le monde va
écouter arrêtons on prend les choses
ensemble
rencontrons nous débattons agissant
ensemble contre le chômage la caravane
des toulonnais paraîtra dérisoire a
beaucoup mais c'est aussi à coups de
petits riens que se fit sur le mur de
l'indifférence
aucune des informations de ce week-end
ne sera à la une demain du journal sud
ouest le deuxième quotidien français qui
emploie près de 1200 personnes est
confronté aux plus graves conflits de
son histoire la direction s'oppose au
syndicat de l'entreprise et a décidé par
mesure conservatoire de fermer
l'établissement donc pas de sud ouest
demain dans le kiosque depuis hier une
ville en france a perdu la tête pour
célébrer la naissance vendredi prochain
du tunnel sous la manche
les habitants de calais font la bringue
louis carzou philippe sur pau a laissé
calais peut-être peut-être mais depuis
48 heures cale est une étrange cité où
les enfants n'ont plus peur des
chauves-souris et dupeux où les engins
de chantier se prennent pour des
majorettes
bref de quoi tourner la tête des idées
aux fils des bourgeoises éternelle
tous venir tous les métiers du père gros
super gros c'était le minimum pour
creuser un tunnel et pour que
calaisienne et calaisiens s'habitue à
leur nouveau compagnon
on leur a montré ce qu'était un tunnel
un endroit de passage plutôt sombre où
toutes les rencontres sont possibles
[Musique]
en perd un lieu sans feu ni loi poids de
piste était vraiment pas ça nul tandis
qu'une veille la disette en flammes mais
à la plus grande joie des habitants car
des chaudronniers fantôme attiré par le
tunnel ont offert à calais la naissance
d'une statue sous leurs yeux
dans un déluge dédain celle qui
transforme l'instant des fusions en une
figure de fonte désormais solide comme
un souvenir d'enfance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pendant une semaine encore fait de
fièvre et de ferveur calais tout entière
a décidé de se hisser sur un piédestal
voilà il se sera sous le soleil il fera
beau demain un peu partout en france
mais attention ensuite ça va se gâter à
partir de mardi la météo d'isabel
martinez et dans un instant puis ce soir
un film policier américain de rémy
harling 58 minutes pour vivre
michel sardou chez nagui fera son
taratata aux environs de 23h et
catherine ceylac présentera le dernier
journal vers 00h30 demain matin dès 6h30
télématin à 13 heures daniel bilalian et
à 20 heures pot la main je vous souhaite
une excellente soirée